it was the syrian president's first
visit to an arab country since an
uprising against his rule began in 2011
but the uae's engagement with the once
widely shunned bashar al-assad is not
new and it has been happening despite
opposition from long-time ally the
united states the biden administration
was swift in condemning the visit saying
it is profoundly disappointed and
troubled by an attempt to legitimize a
leader responsible for atrocities but
many believe this was not just about
bringing damascus back to the arab fold
by hosting assad the uae wanted to make
a statement to the west
look you guys have left us as in the
middle east in a vacuum
by your partial withdrawal
the partnership that we have with the
united states is no longer functioning
you're not delivering on the security uh
on the security guarantees that you're
giving particular as we're looking
towards the jcpoa 2.0 being negotiated
with iran and the uh saying we're taking
over responsibility we you want to share
the burden we are taking the burden but
we're doing it our way
russia's invasion of ukraine has exposed
rifts between washington and its allies
in the middle east the uae and saudi
arabia the gulf nations which host u.s
forces have so far avoided taking a
position against russia it's not just
that they are not supporting u.s
president joe biden's administration as
it tries to cut moscow's lifelines
the uae and saudi arabia are two of the
world's biggest oil exporters
uk prime minister boris johnson was in
riyadh earlier this month to try to
convince the west's long-time allies to
increase production to rein in soaring
energy prices and help end the west's
dependency on russian oil
the saudi
emirati alliance is not so eager
to
support united states and western europe
and europe in general
attempt to stop the russia and ukraine
by refusing to produce and to increase
oil production and to lower gas prices
which making it costly for the united
states and europe
the biden administration has lost
political capital with saudi arabia and
the uae the gulf states were frustrated
by the lack of a strong u.s response
against iran when they were both
targeted by yemen's houthi rebels they
have since strengthened ties with russia
who they believe can contain iran's
ambitions
the war in ukraine is realigning the
political world its outcome will have
far-reaching geopolitical implications
for this region senator al jazeera